welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Jessica Clemens and what the hell is
Madame Webb about respectfully
respectfully of course when I say what
the hell I mean it in a really nice tone
I've seen the trailer I've seen the
poster thank God they got a new one and
I've seen the Ocean Spray and I'm still
a little confused this movie comes out
next month and I don't know anything
about it and I thought I did this video
isn't an attack on Madam Webb at all
this trailer was a lot to take in lots
of exposition mixed with time jumping
and a man who just keeps choking women
and I don't like it I was just trying to
piece a lot together and then something
new would just pop up so I did my own
research and I'm here to tell you
everything you need to know about the
movie before seeing it because it comes
out in less than a month less than a
month I'll also explain how this movie
is actually very important in the Sony
verse no matter how much you might not
want to see it you must because believe
it or not we're leaving the origin
stories and physically stepping into the
Sony verse now through Madame Webb and
here's how but first this video is
sponsored by Squarespace the all-in-one
platform that makes launching your own
website of Breeze be sure to check out
nerd rot. shop to check out the latest
and greatest in new rockstars merch you
can grab a shirt featuring Kingpin or
maybe a shirt featuring the best bubs
Deadpool and Wolverine or maybe one of
our many great other options grabbing
some merch From Nerd r. shop is the best
way to support the channel and all the
work we do here in New rockstars and
what makes me come to work all day cuz
normally I wouldn't this movie drops on
February 14th which will be like my
fourth time seeing a Dakota Johnson
movie alone on Valentine's Day and
according to IMDb emphasis on according
because it's not always correct some
people could just go in there and edit
it like Wikipedia so it's according to
IMDb the stars Dakota Johnson as Madame
Webb Cindy Sweeney as Julia Carpenter
Isabella Merced as Ana corazone Celeste
o Conor as mattye Franklin tahar rahee
as Ezekiel Sims and possibly Adam Scott
as Ben Parker and freaking Emma Roberts
as Mary Parker AKA Spider-Man's mom and
from some set photos it looks like she's
pregnant with our boy and it is a boy
the movie is directed by SJ Clarkson who
directed episodes of The Defenders and
Jessica Jones so you know I'm already in
this movie along with Venom Mobius
Craven will still exist within the Sony
verse so it's all within its own little
web and you know vulture is there now
too this story follows Cassandra Web AKA
Madam web or Cassie web as an origin
story who receives Visions about the
future in small fragments and is
currently protecting three young future
spider women according to Dakota Johnson
this was before Madame Webb was in her
wheelchair and she's hyper intelligent
and these Visions make her feel like
she's going insane and remember it's an
origin story so her Visions are not all
there and not proficient in it as she
gets these Visions she sees a man in a
black suit and mask trying to kill her
and the other women she's protecting
this man is Ezekiel Sims who's framed as
the villain of the story as for
production and synopsis that's what we
know and that was easy to understand
like right truthfully the trailer might
have left you wondering what the hell is
this about and that's okay it introduces
a lot of information without prior
knowledge and it's our job here to clear
up that confusion for you so Bet On It
Eric does the breakdown for the Madden
web trailer if you want those amazing
Easter eggs that lead to theories he
also has a great video about the world
we're selling Madam Webb Craven and
Venom into that's important and
quintessential in the future of the Sony
verse I'll speak on that video later in
here as well but I'll just say this is
our 10-minute video so you're not
confused so what's the whole reason for
this this like most n Universe
franchises it's to lift their future
pictures towards a bigger event or a big
business talk make more money but really
it's working toward a bigger thing they
round out all the characters creatively
get the chance to maybe clear up some
unanswered questions and everyone loves
watching their favorite characters do
crossovers the merch money doesn't hurt
for that either more money that's all
son thinks about is actually that green
so Madam web's origin story with these
key characters will probably lead us to
the importance of the spiderverse in
ways we didn't know really existed I'd
say we learned a lot from across the
spiderverse Miguel O'Hara cleared up
anomalies Canon events and introduced us
to the variant spider men in the spider
Society but Madam Webb introducing
Ezekiel Sims is a game changer and will
throw us into Uncharted Territory in the
comics Ezekiel Sims gets his power by
exploring and undergoing a ritual that
grants him spider-like Powers he tells
Peter that maybe he's not a spider by
choice but by Destiny bringing us to the
web life of Destiny if you watched
Eric's video then you know what that is
still if you don't let me explain and I
promise this will come full circle to
what the movie is trying to accomplish
all the spidies anyone bit by radio
actors spiders tied into the web life of
Destiny there are also spider totems
linked to the web life of Destiny like
the great Weaver the gatekeeper and
others still these totems can choose
their avatars or manifest independently
imagine moonight and konu Peter was the
avatar for the other and Cindy moon was
an avatar for the bride then there's
things like Morin or Morlan however you
want to pronounce it who is a member of
the inheritors who are totems of the
leech the lowest of all totems in the
Multiverse only able to parasite the
powers of others they feed on the life
forces of tmic avatars and gods in one
issue Morin touched Peter and knew where
he was at all times from the single
touch and Ezekiel was like peace dude he
knows where you're at at all times and I
think Ezekiel Sims is a clear McGuffin
for this movie because we see Maddie
Franklin getting her life force sucked
out of her in the trailer I think that
man in the black suit is actually Morlin
who killed and took a Spider-Man's
costume we coincidentally see the man in
the black suit switch between himself
and Ezekiel often and I think that's
Cassandra's fragmented Visions she's
seen Sims from images and how suspicious
he still looks exactly like the
scientist that traveled to Amazon with
her mom back in the day her Visions are
playing games with him or maybe it's
just at one point Ezekiel says
this I have no idea what those girls
have come that's more than plain tricks
on her trying to persuade her into
delivering the girls to him Brandon
believes this could be a possessed Sims
by Marlon which could still stand but I
like to think every time we see these
girls in the Spidey costumes they're
attacking the real Sims who's in hiding
from Morland in the comics he trapped
Cindy moon in a room and I think it was
like to protect her from Morland after
she was bitten he knew the villains were
coming to take out the Spider-Man and
tried protecting them it was literally
insane to kidnap Cindy moon for like 13
years so I think the appropriate version
of that story is him in hiding in his
own home for 13 years which looks to be
true in the trailer all this to say
we're used to hearing it was a
radioactive spider so Madam web will
venture into what if it wasn't a
coincidence recognizing the web life of
Destiny protecting it and giving the
Sony spiderverse their chance to connect
everything around Spider-Man is what
they're aiming to do again I'd ask
myself here well didn't Miguel sort of
make something like that and across the
spiderverse well firstly he made a team
he didn't choose who was bitten though
to note the web of life is also mad web
source of Clairvoyance and how the
Spidey have their Spidey senses so that
connection won't go unnoticed here if
you're a new year new you kind of person
and an online kind of person then it's
really a new year new URL if you're
looking to get the most out of your site
you should check out Squarespace
Squarespace is an all-in-one platform
that provides you with everything you
need to know to do whatever you need
with your website Squarespace has
templates and designs for pretty much
everything so whether you're making your
very first website or sprucing up one
for the new year using Squarespace makes
it super easy to customize your look
update content and add features to fit
your unique needs for instance
Squarespace makes it easy to sell merch
you can design your products and save
time and money by letting Squarespace
handle production inventory and shipping
and if you're selling any other kind of
physical Goods digital Goods or even a
service Squarespace makes it easy to
build your storefront and grow your
business just head to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com neww
rockstars to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain with her
eyes on the Web of Life Madame web
probably guides who gets bitten playing
the role of the master Weaver to it all
even if she's not the master Weaver this
is really important and pivotal to Sony
because they want the franchise to last
and if you need a bunch of Spider-Man to
take on something massive you need that
info from Miguel or the web of life it
seems easier to get that info from
Madame web who sees it all and for
production purposes it can stay in the
live action world for now so lorda
Miller won't have to panic other than
Ezekiel Sim's character being introduced
and being a super McGuffin other
characters are important to Madam web's
lineage people like Julia Carpenter
being played by Sydney Sweeney Julia
Carpenter was a Spiderwoman who showed
up during Secret Wars engaged in a
science experiment gone wrong and
developed superpowers she shoots
adhesive strands of psionic energy which
is still very crazy to me Cassandra Webb
Anya corazone and Julia Carpenter cross
paths when Craven and his gang hunt them
down and kill Cassandra and then she
passes on her powers to Julia Carpenter
making her a new pseudo Madam web Maddie
Franklin played by celesto Conor got her
powers from a ritual that Madame Webb
attended Ana corazone played by Isabelle
merett was chosen by the spider society
and given spider powers she crossed
paths with Madame Webb's Julia Carpenter
and Madam Webb in the comics as well
with those three future spider women
being addressed with these Connections
in the coms comics in the trailer it
shows they somewhat have a connection to
Cassandra still and this must be their
Destiny so another question on
everyone's mind is where is our
Spider-Man well behind door number three
there's no doors here I'm in a blue
dungeon is pregnant Mary Parker from
behind the scenes photos of Beyonce's
debut album on set this would be set
like 20 years ago we're getting a
younger Madame web possibly a young Ben
Parker and a pregnant Mary Parker so in
this world Spider-Man hasn't been born
yet and I naturally would believe maybe
this world Spider-Man is actually these
faad future spider women but you don't
have a pregnant mared Parker and not
give us that baby Spider-Man you know
what I'm saying so there's a reason why
possible young Ben and Mary are here and
I assume it's because Madam web has to
protect that baby what do they say in
Heroes save the baby save the world
something like that my followup question
would be Jessica but why not just let
the baby die because it's a baby you
horrible animals Cassandra is a
paramedic and Ben is clearly her friend
she goes to a baby shower I'm sure that
vision of the baby being delivered in
the wet comes to her at that baby shower
do you think if she saw in the future
this baby is about to be stolen by a
Time jumping vampire that eats people
she just stand by absolutely not so
she's going to protect that baby and
probably enlist these young women after
finding out they are also future Spidey
there's been some questions up in the
air about whether or not that baby is
Andrew Garfield's Peter Parker and
timeline wise I don't think it works
this could be a new Peter Parker for
this universe or an entirely new
Spider-Man that's the thing there simply
might not be a Peter Parker that could
be the Green Goblin this could be a
universe where Mary's baby is just
actually a normal boy because Madame
Webb can shift things if she's able to
guide who's bitten or change the future
you let me know who you think it is
after that research and dive into Madam
web Ezekiel Sims and Morland I'm
actually very excited for this movie
hopefully they don't kill that baby
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
Lulu Clemens follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love check
out the break room and the Deep dive
wait my Spidey senses are
tingling